good afternoon everybody my name is
Sabina Marx I'm the managing director at
the Center for research on environmental
decisions here at Columbia University
and I have the honor to introduce the
event and our speakers today today's
event is the fourth in six events in the
research Without Borders series for the
academic year 2010-2011 it is sponsored
by the scholarly communication program
here at Columbia the Department of
astronomy and season the Center for
International earth science information
network at Columbia University I will
introduce the speakers each of them will
speak for about 20 minutes
and then we'll follow with a discussion
we'll hold questions until the end until
all speakers are done we'll have a
discussion Q&A at the very end we are
videotaping this event so questions from
the audience we're asking that you
please step up to the mic in the aisle
so that your question can be recorded
and also heard by the entire audience
our first speaker today will be David W
Hogg he is an astronomer and physicist
at New York University his research is
on observational cosmology the study of
the universe and its contents with a
concentration on galaxies like our own
Milky Way in addition to performing
traditional scientific research he works
on engineering systems that can manage
and analyze enormous datasets and one of
the spin-offs of this work is astronomy
as Thornton a trauma tree dotnet sorry a
system that automatically calibrates
amateur and hobbyist images of the sky
for using scientific astronomical
investigations it has calibrated tens of
thousands of images on the photo sharing
site Flickr and many more in other
applications his work is supported by
NYU NASA and NSF
as well as the Humboldt Foundation the
second speaker today will be Rick Bonnie
who is the director of program
development and evaluation at Cornell
Lab of Ornithology
where he has worked for nearly 30 years
he's the co-founder of the labs citizen
science program and his research focuses
on first developing projects in which
the public actively engaged in
scientific infinite investigation and
Environmental Conservation in
second-team understanding the social and
educational impacts of public engagement
in science he's the founder and director
of the website citizen science torque
which is devoted to building and
supporting the growing field of citizen
science and he advises numerous projects
throughout North America that are
developing exhibits curricula
interactive websites and community
programs focused on science he is the
co-editor of a book citizen science
scheduled to be published by Cornell
University this year our third speaker
today will be Jane hunter who is a
professorial research fellow in the
school of information technology and
electrical engineering at the University
of Queensland Australia she's also the
director of a research lab where she
leads a team of postdocs PhD students
and software engineers developing
software services for managing and
analyzing scientific and research data
her specific interests include the
application of Semantic Web and social
networking tools to the integration of
distributed datasets for environmental
monitoring and management I would now
like to invite David's W hog to the
podium thank you very much and pleased
to be here the I am the I am the person
in the program who knows the least about
citizen science so it's good that I'm
starting I'm also going to try and
define it but before I define citizen
science I want to show you a few pretty
pictures so the photo sharing site
Flickr I don't know if you know this
photo sharing sites liquor but if you
don't I strongly recommend you check it
out
it is not citizen science per se it's
citizen photography where people upload
photographs and then the social
networking aspect of Flickr brings the
most interesting and most beautiful
photographs to the top and Flickr is the
kind of site that makes you realize that
citizen science as possible because so
much it's possible on this site so
anyway Flickr has millions of photos of
all sorts of things but in particular if
you search for astronomical objects
that's pretty good there's galaxies here
here's nebulae actually if you want to
just explore great photos by amateurs I
suggest you search for nebula on Flickr
because there are such beautiful images
of nebulae but a strange search you can
do is the search that's hard to
pronounce which is astrometry and the
reason you should search astrometry at
some point is because if you click on an
image so I've clicked on a particular
it's very hard to see the images here on
this screen but here's an image that has
been added to the group astrometry so I
don't know if you see this it says the
photo also appears in astrometry group
it's hard to see that at the edge but if
you take an image on Flickr upload an
image on Flickr this is somebody who's
taken a picture of the bat of the Milky
Way from their backyard you can just see
it there and then they added the image
to the Flickr group called the Strama
tree okay so now I'm gonna pan down and
shortly after they added it to the group
a few seconds after they added to the
group you can see a comment got added to
the thing it says here astrometry met he
hello this is the blind astrometry
solver your results are and then it
gives a whole bunch of numbers and then
it tells you that this image contains
things like the NGC 64 75 which is a
globular cluster and so on so we the
what we've built at NYU and University
of Toronto is a system that can take
arbitrary images of the sky and tell you
where they are on the sky and what's in
them and the value of this of course is
it makes images that are taken for fun
into images that are potentially useful
for scientific investigations and then
of course we play all sorts of games for
instance our robot this is
all done by robot of course and our
robot also tags the image you see it's
labeled that little thing is m7 which is
a globular cluster so now if you go on
to Flickr and search for m7 you can find
all the images that our robot believes
contains m7 and m7 is a very interesting
object it's a globular cluster that
contains stars of great interest
including variable stars and phenomena
that are accessible to backyard
telescopes just to one of the big sort
of themes of the stuff I like to talk
about is that the world wide web is
effectively an amazing observatory so
people on the web take images of the sky
all the time and put those images on the
web and they do that for a lot of
different motivations in fact there's a
lot of people on the web who are selling
images a lot of the people who post
images on Flickr are selling images
selling nice prints of images and the
use Flickr is an advertising platform we
took what we did in this this is a
strange diagram but what this diagram is
is a region of the sky this is a plot of
a region of the sky and it's a region of
the sky centered on Orion which is a
very famous beautiful nebula that
astronomers that amateurs like to take
photos of in fact there's 3,500 well two
years ago there were 3,500 images on
Flickr of the Orion Nebula
and what we did is we just asked what do
we see in those images so the red
circles here are cataloged stars
cataloged by a strong professional
astronomers in professional astrometric
catalogs and then the blue dots of which
there's millions of overlapping dots are
stars found in amateur images and the
the punchline of this figure if you're
an astronomer is there is a huge amount
of information about the sky just in the
pretty pictures that people have put on
is on Flickr and we could actually
enlarge our knowledge of the sky just by
mining the images on Flickr this only is
possible once you can calibrate them so
the fact that we can initially have our
robot calibrate the images made this
possible if you were just handed a big
sheaf of images of Orion there's not
very much you could do with them you
have to get them aligned
on the sky and calibrated photometric ly
which is what our robots do here's
another example the there are enormous
numbers of images of comets on on the on
the web comets are one of the things
people most like to take pictures of and
some of them have become very very
bright
in fact comet homes this is commenting
akitoki another comment we've looked at
as comet homes which became so bright
you could just take photos of it with a
little point and shoot camera for a
large part of its passage here what
we've done is we've taken all the images
in on the web we can find of comic haiku
talkie and just aligned them and made a
pastiche of them and what you see is
that not one image of the comet but
thousands of images of the comet that
all come up in a line and because we
because this line is very very well
constrained by the images we can
actually compute common key on
Kentucky's orbit from these images as
accurately as it's currently known in
NASA by the NASA JPL team which tracks
comets so for instance so there's enough
information on the web to reconstruct
the orbits of solar system objects also
of course this tracks changes in the
comment he talk is not so interesting
but some of the comments change
dramatically their appearance and you
can see the appearance change
incompetents
the one nice thing we've learned when
we've done this so to reconstruct the
orbit you actually need to know the
times at which the images were taken
however it turns out that that not all
times are possible with all orbits and
therefore we are able to take the images
that are posted on the web and
recalibrate the clocks and people's
cameras and we find that most people in
fact do have the clocks on their digital
cameras correctly said that was
surprising to us but of course
astronomers tend to be nerdier
photographers than average but one of
the amusing things that was a trouble
for us is that the time setting on a
digital camera does not include the time
zone so we had to infer the time zone
of all the images now some people are
geo-tagging but not everybody is so
there is an amusing sort of backstory
here where we actually learned a lot
about how photographers take photographs
and what issues are with digital cameras
I'm going to come back to the point that
camera times might not be set correctly
going on so I wanted to say what I
thought citizen science was since we're
talking about citizen science most
people in this room know a lot more
about it than I do I would say the most
and I've decided to define it by example
so here's the most minimal I mean not
minimal it's a big project but the thing
that is sort of on one end of citizen
science it would be SETI at home in SETI
at home there's a huge computationally
expensive search for extraterrestrial
intelligence and the way they do their
data processing is by pushing their data
out to people's computers at home the
computer does processing and sends back
results and that way they farmed out
their processing to many computers that
are in just people's homes so that is
citizen science in the sense that the
citizens bought the computers but of
course more interesting things
intellectually interesting things are
things that use people's brainpower and
unique human capabilities to do science
and the next in the stage if I sort of
tried to stage them I would say it was
tagging images so there's a project
galaxy zoo in which people classify
galaxies using human criteria and then
there's an attempt to understand the
properties of galaxies from those human
classifications and amazon has launched
the Mechanical Turk to formalize this
where you can just buy time on large
groups of citizens and if you want to
either use that or be employed by it
it's an amusing interface about which I
can tell many jokes in the question
period then there's projects deeper
projects where people actually take data
for scientists and I think some of those
projects will be discussed next where
where a scientist has a goal and that
goal requires a lot of data taking and
use people so so in the astronomy world
the most impressive thing is the aavso
the American astronomer will start
in which they farm out interesting
variable stars and then astronomers
hobbyist astronomers around the world
take data on those variable stars and
then the aavso re collects that
information and learns about the
physical processes that are affecting
these variable stars there's also a
micro lensing community which is another
interesting one but I don't have time to
talk about it called micro fun going on
further
I actually think some Wikipedia entries
could be thought of as citizen science
the description for instance of black
holes on Wikipedia is one of the best
descriptions that I've seen and that was
sort of a crowdsource description of
course there are a lot of professionals
contributing to that but they're not the
only contributors going further
sometimes web users produce scientific
content on the web without knowing it
and of course a lot of people in in
human sciences use the web as a data set
study social networks and so on but but
it's also the case as I just showed with
my pictures of Orion and comet akitoki
that actually web users are creating
scientific new scientific projects that
they don't even know about by posting
data that are rich and then of course
what I what I want to talk about what I
think the really the long-term goal for
this is to create platforms where
hobbyists can initiate their own novel
scientific investigations and astrometry
net is definitely focused on that but
one thing I should mention is that
amateur astronomers discover a lot of
objects every year a lot of the
supernovae we know about and a lot of
the near-earth asteroids we know about
or we know about because amateurs found
them in fact
often their school kids and and these in
general are hobbyists who aren't working
under the direction of a scientist
they've decided to take this on on their
own and that to me is the most exciting
thing because that to me makes the most
use of the unique capabilities of the
people involved um now I just say a bit
of philosophy and then I will hand over
the floor to Rick one piece of
philosophy is that all metadata are
wrong and this is an old quotation
fact it was about the Semantic Web this
quotation was first I never saw it if
you have Dayton librarians of course
think about this a lot you have data in
general the things that are written
about the data tend to be wrong when the
data were taken what it was taken with
what it's a picture of how it's
calibrated there tend to be mistakes in
part because people who put data on the
web don't really care about whether the
data are wet metadata are correct but as
a scientist using data coming from other
sources especially from sources you know
nothing about like random IP addresses
you have to understand the metadata when
the data were taking and what properties
they have and one solution to that
that's kind of the galaxy zoo and a VSO
solutions to that is to have massive
redundancy make sure every piece of data
gets looked at by many people and you
look for consistency or lack of
consistency in the results and what we
take the attitude we've been taking a
trauma treatment is to build robots that
can vet the data directly and that's
where we in fact we started with this
theme not the citizen science theme when
we were doing astrometry yeah that's
what the sense in which this is a
spin-off another philosophical point
that I'm excited about which I've
already mentioned is that good data
takers might make good scientist so be
good to give them a platform where they
can initiate scientific projects as I
said many discoveries are made by
amateurs and amateurs so amateur is not
a bad word in astronomy in fact
professionals will sometimes describe
their research as amateur astronomy when
when they are doing particular kinds of
activities so for instance amateurs are
much better at taking images of the sky
beautiful images of the sky so a
professional astronomer who's taking
images that need certain properties will
say I'm doing amateur astronomy here and
people will recognize that to mean a
particular kind of very careful
observing and so amateur is not a bad
word in astronomy at all and of course
it means lover or enthusiasts if you
think about the words root and it's
that's been kind of preserved in
astronomy so we would like to build a
platform for to capitalize
on this these capabilities and make it
possible for for hobbyists to do their
to actually generate their own
scientific projects and I'm kind of
vaporware in the sense that we run on we
run on Flickr and we calibrate actually
we've calibrated millions of images now
tens of thousands in Flickr and millions
in other domains but we have yet to
build this platform so I'm not going to
show you results I'm just bringing up
the philosophical points that make it
exciting
oh by the way I should mention that and
I forgot to mention when I was talking
about the aavso there's actually so
quite a bit of citizen science astronomy
being done here at Columbia Joe
Patterson and the Astronomy Department
works on variable sources you with a
group a large group of amateur very very
capable amateurs by the way this was you
can't see this in its proper glory and
you won't be able to see the credit Don
McCrady is the credit he's one of the
and if you search this is an image of
the Pleiades or Subaru in Japanese and
and this is just the most view there's
no professional image of the Pleiades
that I know that shows this level of
detail and if you saw this with proper
contrast there's this great nebulosity
around the stars it's being illuminated
by the stars it's just good so I'm gonna
end by just saying what I think the
challenges are for the my vision of
citizen science so one really big issue
is credit we are we've built this
catalog around the Ryan Nebula it's
involved the contributions of literally
thousands of observers and the question
is how do we properly give them credit I
am already on papers with more than 500
authors but those are the other authors
are astronomers professional astronomers
so it's an interesting question what are
we going to do about scientific credit
not just because amateurs want it in
fact many amateurs don't want the credit
but because it's the right thing to do
from the point of view of scientific
integrity there's a repeatability issue
which is very related to the credit
issue which is how do you make sure that
the sources of data are available and
understandable and checkable um
data management issues are very big for
us so in many cases the data in citizen
science things are very small but not
for us we want all the raw images that
all the amateurs are taking and that can
be more than a thousand gigabytes per
person so right now we're exploring
cloud-based solutions to this but we
don't have a solution to this problem
that's one of the reasons we are not yet
a platform for collaboration it's very
hard problem
there's participation issues which I
think it will come up again in the
subsequent talks what are the best ways
to get people to participate with the
their full capabilities and then finally
my interesting question is can we get
citizen scientists to work together not
just work on a project that is low
located somewhere else but actually work
in self-organized groups I think if we
can achieve that the scientific
capabilities of the world will grow
substantially okay thank you
all right well I'm not content with
small questions I'd like to take on big
challenges and I hope to show you in in
20 minutes
how I think that the concept of citizen
science can actually be world-changing I
as you heard in the introduction come
from the Cornell Lab of Ornithology a
lot of people there may be people here
in the room we haven't even heard of us
before but we are in fact the largest
Department in the College of Agriculture
and life sciences at Cornell with about
250 staff and faculty and grad students
and postdocs I wish I had an hour to
tell you about all the things we do
there I don't but I would like to point
out to you that we do have citizen
science in our mission statement
now here's my definition of citizen
science I'm going to go ahead and read
it which is supposed to be a no-no with
a slide a project or activity in which
the public collects and/or analyzes data
to help understand large-scale research
questions now I think I have some
standing to define citizen science
because I'm the first person to have
used the term citizen science in this in
this regard in the world back in 1995 we
started using it at the lab of
ornithology because we had been doing
public data collection projects for many
many years and we were concerned about
the use of the word amateur yeah it
means lover but it can be denigrating so
we wanted to come up with a new phrase
and we chose citizen science and it has
it has really taken off now when I first
wrote this definition in 95 it didn't
say analyze data it just said collects
data and I've since amended it to
include the data analysis because what
we do in the world of birds and at
Cornell precedes the Internet remember
pre-internet that's it there's a world
out there and there still is beyond the
internet actually and the kinds of
projects that David was talking about
which are really based on analyzing
images from the internet are actually
fairly new to the the public data world
we do have such a project at Cornell
that I'm not even gonna have time to
talk about it today I would like to
point out that there is a rich tradition
of citizen science I don't have time to
talk about all of these
different different early progenitors to
what we do today but just to point out
that amateurs volunteers non
professionals have been forming the
field of science forever in fact they
that's all there were once before there
were places like Columbia and Cornell do
notice the Astronomical Society of the
Pacific 1889 as being early unimportant
probably I could demonstrate to you that
the citizen science program at the Lab
of Ornithology began in the year 1915
when we were formed but probably really
it became more formalized in 1965 when
we started the Cornell nest record card
program in which simply involve people
who were watching birds and finding
their nests contributing data on index
cards and we still have hundreds of
thousands of these of these index cards
in our files but beginning in 1987 with
project feeder watch which now has about
15,000 participants each year and
produces about a hundred thousand check
lists of birds each year and then in the
early 90s the mid 90s as the internet
was developed using the Internet to test
the idea that we could actually collect
data over the internet with the great
backyard bird count we now get about a
hundred thousand checklists and one
weekend every February we turned that
nest record card program into a project
called nest watch which has about 5,000
participants eBird is a year-round
global bird data collection project and
actually I need to update this slide
because it's closer to 2 million
checklists per month now celebrate urban
birds is a year-round simplified version
of eBird and then bird sleuth is a
formal middle school curriculum based on
Ebert as you can imagine each one of
these topics or projects could be
discussed for a full 20 minutes if not
an hour I don't have time to do that but
what I wanted to show you was the the
breadth and the size of our program and
also to give credit to the National
Science Foundation for having put
probably at this point something
approaching almost 20 million dollars
into this program of ours over the last
20 years so when we talk about citizen
science at the lab
ethology we're talking about two major
goals that we have for all these
projects the first is to increase
scientific knowledge and conservation
action so when we say that we have all
these members of the public collecting
data why well the simple answer is
because we can't really understand or
answer most questions about how the
natural world works without hundreds
hundreds or thousands or even millions
of pieces information which are best
gathered by the eyes and ears of the
public and then in a lot of projects we
want to use that information to apply it
to science-based conservation efforts
the reason that I got interested in
citizen science and the reason that the
National Science Foundation has put so
much money into my program is because
we've always had the idea that if people
are participating in the process of
science that they may become more
scientifically literate and by that I
don't mean just all birds have feathers
but there is a process by which data are
collected and analyzed and so when we
say the scientific consensus is thus
that there's a process by which that
knowledge was produced so my idea was if
we can get people involved in this
project in these projects then they may
become much more literate scientifically
and I'm going to sort of come back to
that in a minute or two and show you the
information that we have to suggest that
those things are happening the citizen
science projects that we work with
basically are all about recruiting
people into a project whether it's
bird-watching or butterfly watching or
even in some cases coral reef watching
and to learn the scientific protocols
that scientists have set up to collect
data accurately in a way that it can be
compared by through across and among all
users or data gatherers then gathering
the data in groups individual schools
homes whatever it happens to be
following those protocols submitting the
data to a centralized database where it
can be made available for analysis and
then finally whether you're a
professional or a member of one of these
projects visualizing the results from
all of these databases and learning from
them learning things that you might have
thought were interesting personally or
it's something that you might want to
try to publish
so some of the scientific results or
many of the scientific results that we
have from bird watching projects have to
do with range expansions this particular
slide here shows how the red-bellied
woodpecker is expanding its range north
very rapidly almost certainly as a
result of global warming or climate
change we have put many of our different
projects to work for conservation for
example one of our projects delineated
where all the cerulean Warblers are to
be located in New York so that we could
begin to work with the government in the
Nature Conservancy to expand protection
for these birds and other birds that
live in bottomland hardwood forests and
then of course the education results in
this I could talk about all day or even
all weekend the the bird projects that
we do from the work that my group has
done which is surveys focus groups
telephone surveys pre and post tests
quizzes and on and on and on we know
that people are learning a lot about
bird biology but they're also using our
data analysis tools online to answer
their own questions about vert diversity
abundance and they know that they're
contributing to science so over the last
ten years or so there have been at least
50 articles published in at least 11
journals based on our data and these
include some pretty prestigious journals
all peer-reviewed not only the
scientific findings but also on the
educational social impacts of project
participation so we were asked by the
organizers of this to look at four
different issues data integrity
ownership of results sustainability and
citizen scientists versus simply data
collectors so I'm gonna tie with this
very limited time it's hard to really
get deeply into all of these but I want
to touch on them all and I want to point
out that the kinds of programs that we
do and and others that have been modeled
on ours around the world are really
based on a very complicated program
model you don't just say here's an idea
and you throw it out there and get
people to collect data but you have to
actually go through a process of
choosing a scientific question
developing a team and that really should
also have technologists
and data analysts in it developing and
testing the protocols with people who
are going to participate to make sure
that they understand and that they're
gathering accurate data you've got to
recruit the participants which can be
pretty hard how do you get people to
watch earthworms it's easy to get people
to watch birds but there is a great
earthworm project a Great Lakes
earthworm project with a lot of people
involved you have to train the
participants to be able to follow the
protocols you have to accept the data
into a database and ensure data quality
with a whole data management policy you
have to make those data available to the
public and the professional scientists
you have to analyze and interpret the
data so that they're not just sitting
around uselessly you have to publish and
apply the results or else really you
haven't gone through the whole process
of science and then you need to measure
the effects you decide is this really
effective and should we continue to do
it so I again I don't have time to go
through this whole project model or
program model in great detail it's
published in bioscience magazine that
can give you the the citation for
anybody that's interested but I wanted
to talk just for a few minutes here
about eBird which is our biggest project
I can't do the math there I'm talking
about eBird and show you about some of
these issues so eBird started in 2003 I
have a feeling that this slides going to
be hard to see but it shows the rapid
growth since 2003 in participating and
collecting information about birds not
only from North America but now all over
the world so that we're getting about 2
million about 2 million observations per
month into our database and notice that
line where it says eBird 2.0 launch and
how the curve begins to go up quickly
after that I'm not going to have time to
discuss that now but it might come up
during questions and answers and from
from this we're able to to really
generate some pretty sophisticated maps
here now I'm showing for example how the
annual pattern of say the willow
flycatcher is changing over time and
this is based on millions and millions
and millions of records you know you can
see I'll let that run again you can see
that they first show up in migration
actually in the southwest
over California Arizona area almost
before they start to come back in the
East that wasn't actually even known
before Ebert and then the real white
hotspots show you where their most
common and went throughout the course of
the year we can do this for most species
now and the way that we're able to be
certain about the quality of these data
have to do once again with developing
and testing the protocols so that as we
develop them we make sure that the
people who are going to collect the data
understand them and if they don't we
change them and get them to the point
where they do know how to do them in
terms of the accepting data and ensuring
the data quality the forms that we use
the electronic forms are smart forms
when you go to submit data for eBird you
submit a location and you get a
checklist for that location and for that
time of year and if you were to put in
here an unusual bird or try to put one
in that wasn't on the checklist or you
put in a number which was beyond what
was likely in terms of numbers of
individuals you would get an are you
sure and if you say yes I'm sure you'd
get an email from one of our 500
regional editors all around North
America who would want to query you
further on that information before
deciding whether to accept or deny that
record and then in terms of making the
data available data availability while
all of our data are freely available for
one thing you get a lot of National
Science Foundation funding so we're
required to make it all available but we
would anyway because these data are
collected by the public and they should
be available to the public so you can go
into ebert and you can view and explore
data in a whole bunch of different ways
you can begin to see from this there are
bar charts there are global range maps
there's even a Gulf spill bird tracker
which I won't have time to probably talk
about unless it comes up in the Q&A
about how the National Science
Foundation actually gave us money to
expand eBird into looking for oiled
Birds right after the Gulf oil spill
they actually called us on a Saturday
and said if you can get us the proposal
by Monday will fund you to do this and
also not only can you go into the the
database and generate all those graphs
and charts and maps with does anybody
think this is funny circles and arrows
and a paragraph on the back of each one
explaining
one is to be used as so some people here
remember Washington Square okay anyway
all of the raw data are also available
on the eBird reference data set at the
avian knowledge network and anybody can
publish anything they want and get it
peer-reviewed if they want and all we
ask is that they credit Ebert and the
avian knowledge Network now I think I'm
running out of time so coming back to
the the questions of sustainability and
society identity I'm talking about if
citizen science can really help to save
the world well that's when we have to
really get into analyzing and using the
data this looks complicated it's one of
my favorite eBird results because it
shows you at the Jamaica Bay National
Wildlife Refuge how the height of use of
the refuge by ducks and shorebirds is
not at the same time which might seem
like so uh unless you're the refuge
manager trying to manage the refuge for
both bird watchers and hunters and with
this data here you begin to see you
don't really have a problem you can draw
the refuge down during the short bird
season and let the water back in for the
duck hunters without antagonizing either
group the results have to be published
as I said publications for participants
like our newsletter bird scope but also
in scientific journals and very
importantly in popular articles so that
the world understands the power of their
neighbors to be gathering these data the
information has to be applied into
conservation plans and reports the
government agencies and management
guidelines in the the figure on the
right shows the Tri national vision for
land bird conservation that's Canada
u.s. and Mexico which extensively uses
all of our citizen science data and
coming up with a management plan for all
of the north and Central and South
American birds and then you also have to
be able to measure the impacts in terms
of knowledge action and literacy to be
able to show the world that this is
important and deserves further funding I
want to point out that the work that
we're doing at the lab of ornithology is
not being done in isolation and as a
matter of fact there are a lot of people
really trying at this point to codify
the field of citizen science and this
began with a conference that I and my
colleagues organized that
the Lab of Ornithology in 2007 funded by
NSF was the citizen science toolkit
conference and it resulted in a
proceedings which is actually a whole
lot of fun to read it's very very well
edited by our conference documenter but
it also resulted in the website citizen
science org which is where you can find
the citizen science toolkit which has
all those steps that I showed before
about all the different steps of project
development and each one of those steps
has a great wealth of resources to help
you be able to understand how to do all
of those things when you're developing a
project including evaluation we also
have a lot of other resources on this
site there's a whole tab on here called
climate change which gets into all the
work that again my colleagues and I are
doing in using citizen science projects
at science centers as ways of helping
people to understand the local impacts
of climate change for example we know
through citizen science that birds are
nesting as much as 20 days earlier than
they did as few as 40 years ago which
has a huge impact on a species which has
evolved over time to lay its eggs and
raise its young at a time that Mac when
the most insects are available and if
over because of climate change those get
out of sync it's going to have
devastating impacts on those on those
creatures so we have a whole section on
using citizen science to show to discuss
and teach about climate change which I
wish I had time to tell you and as I
said it's got the steps of the toolkit
now coming back to this question about
citizen data collectors versus citizen
scientists you can very quickly say how
are people really going to become
scientists if all they're doing are
collecting data just like a bunch of
graduate students well a couple years
ago the National Science Foundation
asked me to convene a group to actually
do a white paper a position paper on
citizen science and we ended up spending
about a year and a half doing this paper
and we actually called it not citizen
science but public participation and
scientific research which is a bigger
umbrella term that includes citizen
science but some other things what do I
mean by other things when we stop and
think about the steps in the scientific
process there as all of you who are
scientists know
a whole bunch of different things that
you have to do from beginning to end to
really get something understood and
published and in typical scientific
investigation if scientists or
technicians that do all the work the
question then is with public
participation what do you want those
public participants to do and we
realized when we started doing a
meta-analysis I can use the word meta
when we started doing a meta analysis of
a whole bunch of different projects that
are out there based on a evaluation
rubric that we created we discovered
that they sorted into three basic models
in citizen science basically as a
contributory model where participants
are collecting and maybe analyzing
samples but there are a lot of other
projects that we labeled as
collaborative projects in which the
participants are working with scientists
to do a whole lot more they may be
developing explanations for questions
they may be actually analyzing data that
they're collecting not only data that
have been collected by others and then
there's another whole category of
projects called co-created projects
where the public are actually involved
in the coal question from very beginning
to end a lot of these have to do with
like pollution type projects and they
quickly move into a lot of social
justice issues so for example the marvel
monarch larva monitoring program which
is at the University of Minnesota Karen
oberhauser and her colleagues used our
report to get NSF funding to really
begin to move her contributory project
into a co-created one where the
participants in the project they're not
just collecting data but they're
beginning to ask and answer their own
questions about butterflies in the
process heidi ballard a colleague of
mine from UC davis has done extensive
work with people who are harvesting
Solal in the pacific northwest and she
took 25 mostly undocumented migrant
workers who were harvesting this this
ornamental evergreen and they developed
a whole sustainability project from
beginning to end to make sure that they
were harvesting the Solal in a way that
would be there for them and their
families in future generations so the
idea that you can work with the public
to really do a project from beginning to
end is very much very much there
so this is I think my last slide and the
the the toolkit conference that we did
in 2007 was really just the beginning
we're having a second citizen science
NSF sponsored conference at the American
Museum of Natural History in April fact
I spent yesterday there working on the
plans for that the there's a huge
project called data one and that might
come up in the next talk or it might not
or maybe Q&A but data one is a huge NSF
funded initiative to try the simplest
way to understand it is to get all the
biological databases in the world to
begin to talk to one each other in an
informed way and so I'm the the co-chair
of the citizen science working group for
data one trying to come up with best
practices for data management needs to
inform and work with the field of
citizen science and having a conference
there pretty soon www.eso.org is a group
at a colorado state that has already
developed a data agnostic or a taxon
agnostic platform for invasive species
projects field scope at national
geographic just got three million
dollars from NSF that do a similar
project the citizen science Alliance
brings together a lot of projects like
the one that David spoke about in the
last few minutes science for citizens
dotnet is a site that you can go to
which is not aimed as ours as citizen
science org is aimed at the professional
but science for citizens is aimed at the
amateur who wants to participate to help
them find one of the many hundreds of
projects that are available and then
finally we are now starting an
association for citizen science of
professional association citizen science
tour will be its website and over the
the next few months were developing
plans for an online open access journal
for people who are involved in
developing projects and I don't know if
I went over and sorry if I did but
that's that's my spiel thanks
good afternoon everyone my name is Jane
hunter I'm from the University of
Queensland in Brisbane Australia
and you may have seen Brisbane on the
news recently because we've been
experiencing the effects of climate
change in the firsthand basis I think
this year we well the end of 2010 2011
we've been impacted by floods by
cyclones by bush fires I was telling
people last night we've had locust
plagues and we're just expecting
pestilence next I'm not sure what we've
done
so I'm from the University of Queensland
which is in Brisbane and I run the
research lab there and I'm not a citizen
scientist but what my group does is we
develop software services for scientists
and for scientific data management and
we've become very aware recently that
many of the groups that we're working
with are going to be increasingly
relying on citizen science data so I can
probably skip the definitions of citizen
science but what I think is important is
although Rick pointed out that it's been
around since the 19th century
I think the advent of web-based
technologies and mobile technologies is
going to accelerate the adoption of
citizen science by scientists and the
involvement of the public in these
programs so I've got a number of points
at the bottom here where the internet
social networking tools increasing
public awareness of climate change the
availability of technologies to capture
data immediately from the field and the
requirement for large-scale longitudinal
studies both over time but over space is
going to require contributions across
large communities because individual
researchers can't generate that data on
their own and scientific groups as well
can't generate the data they need to
rely on public participation so often
the data is used to complement
scientific studies
we've heard from Rick about the Cornell
Lab of Ornithology in the avian
knowledge Network
there's also the internet bird
collection which is similar to David's
project where the community uploads
photos and videos and audio files in
summer I've got a fellowship to work
with the nature mapping foundation which
is based at the University of Washington
in Seattle to help analyze their data in
Australia we have the Atlas of living
Australia project where I'm a CI on that
project and they're using citizen
science contributions for monitoring
changes in biodiversity and then there's
phenology projects such as plant watch
project budburst and citizen citizen
weather observer program a couple of
other interesting citizen science
projects fold it which is an online game
where people contribute to protein
folding solutions Galaxy Zoo which David
spoke about where the general public
helped with classification of galaxies
based on their shape and in Australia
another project that we have which is
not in the area of environmental
observations or biodiversity but the
National Library of Australia is
engaging with the public to correct the
results of OCR of digitized newspapers
and that's been very successful from
their perspective so recently the
taxonomic data working group had their
annual meeting t DWG and they had a
plenary session on citizen science and
they came up with a list of requirements
that are common across many citizen
science programs firstly they identified
that many scientists do not trust the
data so a common expression that you
hear from scientists is wisdom of the
masses is an oxymoron okay so we have to
try and overcome that so the TD wwg who
are a group of biodiversity data
managers identified that there's a
desperate need for tools to improve the
quality of data
so they want tools too when we say
quality we're talking about the accuracy
and precision of the data the
correctness of the data the completeness
of the data are there any gaps in it
consistency in the data and the
timeliness of the data is it relevant is
it recent how recent is it so they
require tools to detect error and bias
and remove the error and bias to detect
outliers inconsistencies and gaps and as
David point out one of the approaches to
that to detecting outliers and
inconsistencies is ensuring that you
have duplicate data sets or do you have
a ground truth that you can compare
against so can you get multiple people
contributing to the one data set and
doing comparisons in order to get some
statistical averaging we want online
taxonomies simple tools for species
identification tools to measure the data
reliability online training services and
well-designed websites that attract and
retain volunteers that enable the
generation of large sample sizes
duplicate samples provide rewards and
recognition to volunteers and also
provide volunteers with feedback on
mistakes that they might be making in
their data or the quality of their data
so the objectives of this project that
we're running within the e research lab
are to firstly improve the quality and
reliability of the data and secondly to
actually measure the trust and
reliability so that when scientists go
to reuse the data we can filter out
unreliable or untrustworthy data so to
improve the quality it's very important
not to impact on the complexity of the
tools the data capture tools and the
upload tools so we're using behind the
scenes controlled vocabularies and
schemas we're trying to automate as much
as possible the data and metadata
capture we're ensuring that users are
registered and authenticated
previously I'll give you an example the
case study that we're using is coral
watch if the contributors are anonymous
you're more likely to get unreliable
data now so we use xml schemas to
automatically validate the data on the
input we're trying to identify the gaps
and target volunteers towards those
areas we're doing comparisons of the
data with ground truth data were
available to check for consistency or
comparing duplicate datasets in the
wrong same area and then the aim is to
identify and remove erroneous data now
with regard to trust and reliability
we're looking at various methods as I'm
going to go into those in more detail
but we're going to use social networking
tools where users rank each other and
rank datasets and then we can use
inferencing across those networks to
infer the reliability of a particular
set across the network and to filter the
results based on that so the
technological framework that we're
developing a is aimed to match the
platform that Rick described so he's got
a platform for establishing citizen
science programs so we're looking at
what common software tools can we
develop which would be applicable across
a lot of these programs so we're
developing the validation and
consistency checking methods were using
tools such as web 2.0 Twitter smart
phones for real-time data acquisition
we're using the trust metrics to filter
out the unreliable and untrustworthy
data and we're developing actually tools
such as collaborative tagging tools
visualization tools and social network
analysis and visualization technologies
overlaid on top of the underlying
citizen science databases so the case
study I'll describe today is coral watch
and it's a citizen science project which
aims to improve the information on coral
bleaching events and coral bleaching
trends in the context of the Great
Barrier Reef
which is off the coast of Queensland
it's based at the University of
Queensland and it involves 1300
volunteers from over 80 countries and
over 30,000 surveys so the amount of
data that we have is nowhere near as
great as eBird so we're looking for
other case studies to do more analysis
and evaluation of our technologies but
it's an easy one to work with because
they're local and they need help
so coral watch involves the use of these
cold health charts and it usually
involves student volunteers scuba diving
groups or marine scientists who go out
and tourists on the Great Barrier Reef
who go out they use these charts while
they're snorkeling or scuba diving and
they follow reefs transects along the
reef and they collect information about
the color of the coral by comparing it
to this chart so for example staghorn
corals are compared against II 1 to e 6
and if the colors a 1 it's highly
bleached if it's a 6 it's very healthy
they collect this data so there's a
actually reef education package and
there's a downloaded form and in the
past they've downloaded the form which
is they then have these let's see water
proof sheets that they can also put them
inside they snorkel along and they can
tick off boxes someone collects those
forms and then fax us them back to the
coordinator at the University of
Queensland so we've been working on
online data entry forms and the ability
to upload Excel spreadsheets so that the
coordinator at UQ doesn't have to
collect all this paper and do it
manually so the actual data they
collected metadata the contributors
details the survey itself the reef name
Latin long date time the method they
used water temperature weather
conditions the location of the point or
transect along the transect the coral
species and then the bleaching or color
data now they had an original system
version 1.0 which was based on manual
input of the data from paper forms so
we've been developing these new online
forms we've developed a new metadata
scheme
which the input gets validated against
we've developed a PostgreSQL database
we've enabled user registration and user
profiles batch upload we've migrated all
the legacy data across to the new
database and in the process we analyzed
the errors and develop scripts to
correct the errors and to identify where
data was missing so we developed data
validation and verification services
user and survey ranking tools trust
computation services and then the
web-based search browse analysis and
visualization services so this shows the
overall architecture I probably won't go
into too much details here if anyone
wants to if there any technical people
and they want to know more but it's all
web-based we use open layers so you can
use either Bing Maps Google Earth or
Yahoo Maps for the visualization we do
that because Microsoft are funding the
project and so they want us to use Bing
Maps and yet a lot of our community uses
what I use Google Earth so we support
both ok so analyzing the Kuril watch
data and it was very interesting and
what we found was one of the most common
problems was missing doubt data and the
missing data was generally the latitude
and longitude of the location so without
that you'd think the data was fairly
useless but often they'll have the reef
name there and so we have a course
location based on the reef name we enter
the reef name into a service and a web
service called bio geomancer and that
gives us the Latin long incorrect data
the most common problems were missing
temperature the temperature was in
Fahrenheit not centigrade so it was the
wrong units the latitude and longitude
might be transposed the latitude and
longitude might be negated the
coordinates are missing altogether or
they're outside the country range so
those most of those we can correct
easily by doing range checks but it
invalid data as well so they
example have shown here the most common
invalid data was the coral color data
would be wrong so instead of putting II
1 for bleaching and II 6 for the dark
color they would get them around the
other way and put each 6-4 the bleaching
and a 1 for the healthy coral and here's
another example here
someone's entered the data for hair in
Ireland they've got the time is midnight
but they've got full sunshine so that's
you know clearly you can pick that up
and then the validation services I won't
go into that into much detail but this
is just again the repetition of all the
different tools that we've been using
and developing to validate and verify
the data on submission there's an
example of the input form for creating a
new survey the usual sort of smart forms
it pulls it down and discuss comparisons
and alerts the person who's contributing
the data if there are any problems if
they have a GPS device then they can
enter the data directly otherwise if
they haven't got a GPS it gives them a
map location and they could go to that
map get the GPS from that map actually
creating the survey where they input the
color coding and the type of coral and
then we under did undertook the data
cleansing and we found that by doing
analysis of the data and verifying and
validating it against our control
vocabularies and our range checks we
were actually able to correct
approximately 80% of the syntactic
errors and the missing data which is
fantastic the big problem we had is that
we couldn't do semantic validation there
could still be wrong data there and this
is particularly difficult if there are
no sources to compare the data with or
you haven't got any historical data and
this is where we decided to have a look
at social trust metrics and social trust
algorithms are commonly used on the web
in applications such as eBay and there
are different algorithms eigen trust
advocated org and film trust so we
wanted to do an analysis of the
different trust metric algorithms to see
which one was the most relevant and
could be optimized for the context of
citizen science projects
so these recommender systems usually
used for recommending particular
services or applications or products for
example moving ratings they're used in
Amazon and they're used in eBay and they
generate a predictive trust between
users assuming that you can infer trust
or that it's transitive across the
network so for example if I rank someone
I know Peter with five stars
Peter ranks Abdul with three stars I
don't know Abdul but the system then
assigns a trust between Jane and Abdul
of three stars and there's algorithms
such as this one here which is the one
used by film trust so we're analyzing
these different algorithms at the moment
but there are other significant factors
that we wanted to incorporate as well so
the contribute is wrong are they a
scientist are they a government employee
are they a student are they a teacher
are they a volunteer are they a tourist
within particular groups age is very
important so in the K to 12 group their
age whether they're in grades 3 5 7 or 9
the quality improves as they get older
the amount of training the contributor
has undertaken and whether that training
has been online training or personal
one-to-one training their experience
so generally observers improve over time
by approximately 5% improvement a year
over past the first year so the
frequency of contributions in the
duration of contributions are important
and then also the quality of their past
data can we compare their previous data
with some ground truth data to detect
the number of errors incorporate that in
their trust ranking so what we've been
looking at is how to calculate an
accumulative trust value for particular
user based on their expertise aged range
training frequency and duration quality
of past data and a trust ranking
assigned from other members if
it's available and how can you then in
calculate an aggregate trust and we
assign weightings to all those different
attributes and come up with the value
between zero and five stars so this
person for example has three stars out
of five so we have a person ranking tool
here I've logged in I'm looking at a
particular person Bakar and I can see my
trust ranking I've given him four stars
but the community has given him three
stars so the Community Trust is less
than my value individuals can see the
rankings that they give others and they
can see aggregate rankings that they've
been given they can't see the individual
rankings and other people have given
them because we don't want to deter
contributors from coming back we don't
want them to turn into malicious
contributors we want to encourage them
so they can see their aggregate ranking
but not the individuals and then you can
also have a look at the social trust
graph so how it's calculated so here you
can see the relationship between Charlie
and bekar Charlie bakar the
administrator and Charlie Burke are and
then the other people that the
administrator knows so this shows the
network that's being used to calculate
the inferred trust and finally we've
been developing these Google Earth and
time line interfaces Bing Maps and time
line interfaces for searching the data
so for example someone's entered the
query show me all the corals watch
observations for masthead reef between
2007 and 2009 but only those with the
ranking of two or more stars I've
actually shown you here the rankings of
all of them from one star to five stars
so pink is one star purple is five stars
but so it's this filtering of data and
presentation of data based on quality
which is the outcome that we're looking
for so where are we now we're working on
a valuation of the algorithms and the
waiting's and the methods were
accumulating the trust values how are we
going to actually evaluate this so we
want to be able to have a look at the
precision of
data sets before and after we apply this
filtering of the data based on trust so
we need to have the ground truth data
and this is where we're looking at what
data we've got at the moment and how we
can overlay the two and compare the two
we also need to evaluate the performance
and efficiency of the tools there's
scalability and adaptability there
usability and we need to undertake user
feedback surveys with the stakeholders
involved in the projects as well as the
contributors so this evaluation is what
some of what we're doing at the moment
we also want to in particular evaluate
these tools in the context of other
citizen science projects other than just
choral watch which is what we've been
working on at the moment so we've been
talking talking to Birds Australia and
climate watch Australia as well and the
nature mapping foundation in Seattle at
the University of Washington
so future work issues which I think are
very interesting you can't assume that
those trust metrics are static they're
going to change over time so you don't
have to recalculate them either because
the individual it's not necessarily
going to get better all the time
after duration so individuals may
actually get worse over time I know
myself as I get older you know the
quality of my contributions may worsen
so periodic recalculation will be
important and how frequently would you
have to do that we've been developing
the annotation tools for the data sets
and for the individuals we do need to do
more work on that because we're just
tagging based on quality from the
scientists who are involved but we might
also want to tag potential outlying data
so people can go back and look at that
more closely the other area that I think
is very interesting is how do you
identify attacks by malicious
contributors and then how do you remove
them so at the moment there's a time
delay before the users contributed a
certain amount of data
and before the community gets to know
them before you can identify malicious
attacks we'd like to reduce that latency
we're working on correlating the coral
watch data the observational data with
Ames data
that's the Australian Institute of
Marine Science they actually have coral
bleaching data from scientists generated
through monitoring programs but also
they're deriving bleaching events
deriving it from motors satellite
imagery that gives them sea surface
temperatures and there's a correlation
between sea surface rising sea surface
temperatures and bleaching events but
things like high nutrient levels or poor
water quality are also relevant there so
can we use that as the ground truth for
comparison statistical analysis of the
data to identify gaps and target
volunteers at those gaps in those data
it's interesting that most of the data
that we get corresponds to Heron Island
Brampton Island where else um where the
major tourist sites are okay so it's
like I like to ask Rick if they get
large observation the frequency of
observations correlates with where the
population happens to be so how do you
remove that bias from the data we want
to evaluate the existing tools in the
context of other projects and then
finally we need to do more work we've
started working on this we have a
project a PhD student working on this
but it's the smartphone and ipad
interfaces to enable data capture in the
field online species identification keys
and notifications to subscribe users
when they enter a place where there are
citizen science programs going on and to
let them know what citizen science
projects what data needs to be captured
in that area so to conclude as Rick said
and as David said citizen science is
exploding but across many disciplines I
believe there are many common challenges
there is a critical need for automatic
techniques to improve the quality and
trust of the data I think you need to
combine data quality enhancement and
social trust metrics to improve the
reliability and essential component are
the analysis and visualization tools I'd
like to acknowledge
abdul-allah Barry who's a PhD student
working on this Dianna Klein and the
coral watch community who we've been
working with Microsoft Research and
there's my contact details and some
websites on the projects if you need
more information thank you I would like
to invite our speakers to the table in
the front for the next part of this
session which is the UA is very very
interesting to hear all these talks
so you mentioned chain you mentioned
something in your talk that actually
kind of puzzled me so you said that
there was a difference between where the
training came from if it was online or
in person so what was the difference and
why do you think that is well this is
not actually research that we've done it
was in a paper which I read and I can't
remember who it was that identified this
but what they found was that if it's
person-to-person training so for example
in coral watch when it's tourists who
are with a particular dive group then
they usually have silent someone with
them and the dive group who shows them
the protocol teachers and the protocol
for collecting the data and explains it
to them and then helps them as they go
along while they're collecting the data
so that's person-to-person training
online training is where they just
perhaps it's an online test they have to
read some documents and then they might
have to undergo a test to check that
they've understood through your
scientific protocol for collecting the
data and I'll see if I can find the
paper for you but what they identified
was that generally the people who have
undergone personal training with you
know a teacher collected better quality
data than just undergoing online
training we have some research about
that too from our nest watch project
because in the nest watch project you
can either go online and read all the
protocol
and can take a quiz which we encourage
people to do before they submit their
data but we also for a while had a lot
of regional training programs going on
at nature centers and we did not find a
difference in fact we found that the
people who were participating in the
hands-on face-to-face training were less
likely to submit data than the people
who came online and we think it's
because they the fact that they were in
these workshops was because they were
less confident to begin with so you
really have to understand a lot about
the motivations and the aspirations and
the knowledge of the participants before
they even enter training to be sure
about your outcomes there it's very
complicated
another question for Jane after you
implemented your star rating have you
seen any effects of users reacting to
their rating have people that got bad
ratings started getting better at this
stage we've mainly been working just
with the choral watch people themselves
who are involved because they wanted
before we put this out in the public
with all of their public communic
contributors they wanted to understand
precisely how it worked so we're just
working with the choral watch people
themselves because they're scared that
we're going this approach will scare off
their contributors so we're undergoing
testing in the next few months with a
small group of volunteers to just
understand the response of the
volunteers themselves to this system one
thing that's really really noticeable is
that in sort of web 2.0 web sites that
where people share images and video and
so on there are very big differences in
the the nature of the of the sort of
inter member communications my joke
about this is that on Flickr people are
very very supportive of one another and
try to comment in ways that are very
constructive and positive and on YouTube
people just insult each other openly of
their opening and to me it's really
there's just a huge difference which and
I don't think the issues about where how
that appears are really understood these
differences in culture response to red -
where to
it's interesting because in some
situations some applications the ranking
works really well too let's see make
people more competitive so they want to
contribute so they want to improve their
rating their ranking in other systems
that kind of ranking is kept hidden and
it's only used you know behind the
system to filter out data so this is
where we need to identify what's the
best approach for which particular city
science citizen science project so it
may vary across them yeah and we have
the same thing going on in Ebert and
eBird the participants don't actually
have the opportunity to know who the
other participants are they don't talk
to each other
we have rankings but you don't know your
ranking public doesn't know we know
behind the scenes a lot about the
quality from individuals but to
complicate this again again I want to
bring in motivations to participate in
the projects in the first place so for a
very long time we thought everybody's
going to want to be a scientist and we
actually have some pro bono work done
many years ago by a huge advertising
company Ogilvy Mather and they came up
with a great advertising campaign that
was lend your brain to science well not
all of it just the part that counts
birds and it didn't work and I'm glad it
was pro bono because it would have cost
me a lot of money for that for that
failed experiment when we started e bird
it was the same thing count birds for
science well remember that graph I
showed and I said pay attention to that
line what really started to go up when
we introduced eBird 2.0 what we did
there was we gave up trying to get
people to count birds for science and
what we said was manage your online life
list for free and up until that point
you had to spend a lot of money to get
software that would do this but now if
you go into e bird you can put all your
birds in there there's a lot of
different ways that you can put them in
a lot of different protocols you showed
us a lot of detail about coral watch
which I didn't have time to do with
either but there's traveling counts and
stationary counts and
there's just a lot of ways to put your
information in there you can do it from
your home your office your vacation spot
and you can manage all of those
different life lists you can go in there
and say okay when did I see my first
Bluebird at the main cottage in 2003 and
it's going to tell you and it's all free
so right now I would I can't prove this
but I'm pretty sure that most people are
using Ebert just to manage their data
and the benefit is that we get that
information now do we want to rate them
do we want to rate you know there's just
so much more more work that has to go on
here I would add one other thing though
which is that in last year's evaluations
of our great backyard bird count we did
a whole lot of quizzing for the first
time we did some pretty sophisticated
quizzes of bird identification skill and
one of the things that and we also ask
people to self rate themselves in a
different part of the survey and we
discovered an astonishing correlation
between people's self rating and their
answers on those skills so people in the
bird-watching world do know how good
they are with the one caveat that women
underestimate themselves consistently
actually that it's very interesting the
point about providing a service because
we we find we find also that the only
real way to to obtain full imaging
datasets from astronomers is to work
with a site that they're using to
display their full imaging datasets so I
think it really is a beautiful idea if
the citizen science can capture
something that's of great value to the
people for for their hobbies
in a way perhaps this is a follow on I'm
wondering do you have any information or
data on the extent to which these the
participation complementary projects is
competitive or complementary in other
words are the people engaged in one
project likely to be engaged in an
independent project as well because
they're interested in the same field or
did they tend to cluster around a
project that they know that the
astronomer strom between that people
also take part in Galaxy Zoo or I see I
noticed that Rick showed an image of
somebody using a telescope to image
Birds Eye God is a great question to
which I know I don't know the answer at
all but I can say something irrelevant
on the side of it which is that just if
you look at if I look at people I know
who are great amateur astronomers they
also tend to be very outdoorsy they're
often also bird watchers they have an
interest in all sorts of scientific
subjects so I am I feel very confident
that there are correlations strong
correlations and Jane said something
very interesting about the idea of
having your mobile phone said hey you're
in a location where we need more X and I
bet there are people out there who are
interested in a wide range of things and
would participate but might but my data
don't don't support you because we do
lots and lots of user surveys of all of
our different projects and we always ask
great backyard bird count participants a
bird nests watch we always say are you
involved in these other citizen science
projects and we give all kinds of
options I think we've even asked about
reef which is not the same thing as
Florida watch it's not about bleaching
it's about reef fish populations but and
we've asked about Galaxy Zoo and we
don't we don't see the overlap you're
you're doing the bird projects or you're
not and a lot of times when people ask
me for help in trying to conceive or
write especially NSF projects and
they've got this taxon that they want to
study I really shake my head and they
say how many people really want to go
studies segmented worms and I think when
you're working with something that's
already a hobby you've definitely got a
leg up that's not to say that it can't
be done and we shouldn't try but it's
gonna be hard but yeah I agree and that
relates to the other point about
providing back services that are you
valuable to people that you really want
to capture things and we're in a lucky
space where we work on subjects that
lots of people think are cool but it's
it's much harder in areas that are more
esoteric beautiful so a study could be
done on that by working with the website
that I showed you that was showed you
the URL anyway it's science for citizens
net which is actually a for-profit
website I don't think they've made any
profit yet I think they aspire to but
it's an awesome opportunity to really
speak to the public as aspiring citizen
scientists and it would be really a lot
of fun to work with that group and do
some do some studies about people's
willingness to participate in a variety
of projects because that's that website
would be where you'd get the audience to
study I think the the other it is an
issue in Australia there's reef check
and there's coral watch and you talked
at Menten reef there's also projects for
capturing data about manta rays about
dugongs about turtles so how does
someone choose and usually they choose
because the organizational group they
belong to has been approached by someone
so for example many of the fishing
trawlers of the east coast of Australia
the fishing organizations and individual
fishermen are approached for capturing
information about whales or dugongs so
it is a case of whoever approaches them
first so the schools of Townsville are
approached to take school kids out to
the reef to collect data and if they're
approached by reef check first they'll
go with reef check if they're approached
by coral watch first but you're also
assuming that the tools and technologies
are simple enough that it's not onerous
for them to do this as part of either
the school
or as part of you know we need
undertaking fishing yeah actually that's
an interesting point that relates to the
things that all three of us spoke about
is that all three of us aspire to have
systems that are a general purpose and
that might make the environment less
competitive in the sense of permitting
people to participate in multiple
systems sort of easily or transparently
we have that problem even at the lab of
ornithology so you're a birdwatcher and
you go to our website do I want to do a
burr burr feeder watch or celebrate
urban birds what's the difference among
all these projects anyway and one of the
things that we're building now it's not
a project I know a lot about it is a
Cornell Lab of Ornithology project is
called yard map and it starts out by
actually using online software to map
your yard you know where the the shrubs
and the ponds and the trees and so
obviously it's probably not gonna be
terrific in the Upper West Side but at
least for the people who have a yard to
map what it is then going to do is get
them to start reporting the birds that
are in their yard and they're not gonna
have to worry about which project
they're in and in fact something that
most people don't really know or
understand about our projects is that
they actually all talk to each other if
you put your data into eBird well it's
it's just one big database and these
different projects are almost marketing
applications to different audiences
I'm a different type of question when
you start out just getting people
involved they're not really the subjects
of your research but obviously as soon
as you start evaluating them groups like
Denis institutions like NSF in
universities like Columbia well you know
require you to abide by human subjects
and so forth so I'm just curious as to
what your experience has been has that
been a barrier is a issue moving into
the fact that you are dealing with
people and affecting their lives and
evaluating it is an issue but not for me
so Diana Kline who runs the choral watch
project it's an issue for her so when I
think when the people sign up to
contribute they also sign some kind of
you know agreement to release the data I
don't know that there's any ethics
involved in the choral watch but they
definitely sign an agreement to make the
data available but from my perspective
it's not an issue but we could help with
having online data agreements and you
know that kind of thing yeah we do have
to get IRB approval for all of our
evaluation work but thus far it's all
been exempt I've had to get letters that
show that it's exempt but for those of
you who deal with IRB I don't remember
the wording but there's a clause in
there that says something about if this
project can be thought of as simply an
educational project where you're
involving people in learning then it's
exempt because we're not actually
manipulating the people we're not
actually experimenting with the people
yeah but clearly at some point some of
the questions we'd like to answer will
and then we'll and then we'll get and
then we'll get IR beam also I think
establishing personal profiles for
individuals who are involved then you're
starting to get into the issues of
personal privacy and personal data and
yet that information is very valuable
both for providing relevant training and
other information but also when they're
doing searches inquiry so personalizing
and customizing these search and query
results so I think there's a lot that
can be done there but there are also the
personal privacy issues that need to be
considered
I have two questions one as appears very
interesting for the validation of the
data collected by the inner amateurs Jim
mentioned one possible methodology using
Saturday the image the commodious you
mentioned I don't know I wonder you have
more explain ideas second one has very
interesting Wells forty some years ago
when I was a kid and I often heard the
term popular science for the difference
of the classical science so reason that
I heard the word at the term of the
citizen science and wonder anyone has
tracked the term historically thank you
so I'll respond to the first part of the
question and I'll let you to respond to
the second so the coral reef scientists
that we're working with they're
interested in the impact of climate
change on coral reef ecosystems and in
particular the correlation between
climate change and frequency of
bleaching events and what's the cause of
bleaching events and is there anything
that can be done to mitigate the effects
of bleaching now in order to do that
that they have determined that a number
of factors caused coral bleaching one of
them is rising sea surface temperatures
so when the sea surface temperature goes
above I don't know it's might be 22
degrees centigrade then there's much
more likelihood of bleaching but it's
not just sea surface temperature it's
also the water quality so if there's
high turbidity or high nutrients so when
we have high rainfall events in
Queensland such as we've had recently
then you're getting a lot of the soil
and a lot of the pesticides from cane
farming and other types of farming and a
lot of nutrients from you know human
sewage washed into the rivers think
washed out into the bays and onto the
reef that also has a big impact but with
the motors satellite imagery they could
analyze that imagery to derive sea
surface temperature results okay and so
if there's a correlation between sea
surface temperature when it goes above
you know 22 degrees centigrade and
you've also got high turbidity in the
water then you're more likely to get
bleaching so then we want to overlay the
actual coral watch data with the
satellite imagery and with but only the
satellite imagery for the particular
period when the sea surface temperature
goes above 22 degrees and you've got
high nutrients and sediment in the water
so using that kind of overlay of data to
look for correlations and detect
outliers as well so on that point one
the one of the most interesting things
about amateur astronomy is the ability
to detect anomalies and both of you two
mentioned the fact that you look for
outliers and outliers of suspects and of
course even in astronomical data almost
all outliers are suspect but
occasionally in outliers of enormous
interest and sometimes is more
interesting than all of the aim liners
and there's several couple of issues
here one is that you happen have layers
of other data like we're just like
satellite data sometimes and of course
you specifically mentioned that there
can be inconsistencies in the way people
fill out forms which allow you to
identify things but but you definitely
want to be open to finding outliers and
investigating them and I know one place
where that came up is Galaxy Zoo and one
of the things they did is they kept a
sort of open-ended forum for people to
just discuss outliers and then that
open-ended forum actually led to some of
the most important discoveries in the
project were these outliers but I do
think when when the number of records
gets enormous like you're facing it's
very hard to see like automated and
robust way
as you can find the LP interesting
outliers so there was also the question
about popular science mm-hmm
but I'm not sure if I really understood
the second part of the question well you
were asking about the term popular
science right what happened to that term
I think not I mean I think of popular
science as being the science that's
accessible to the public in a certain
way and of course a lot of what people
in this room do is may try to make
science more accessible for the public
and I think citizen science much more
implies a participation direct
participation and not just that the
understanding that whoa but I'd
certainly know nothing about the
Anthropology of the terms doesn't work
right when we were working on the report
for NSF where we were trying to define
the field of citizen science we ran into
so many different terms there's
community science and civic science and
we hadn't even thought about popular
science but participatory research
participatory action research and others
that I'm forgetting and that's why we
went out on a limb and came up with our
new term public participation in
scientific research to encompass all of
those and that's why we came up with
those three to three new categories with
boring titles contributory and
collaborative because we were trying to
get away we didn't want to try to
redefine any of those other ones that
had already been used now we're working
on a paper right now that presents five
models rather than three and one of
those is the the d.i.y or whatever the
do-it-yourself the the folks that are in
their basements inventing amazing stuff
and to me those are the people that are
subscribed to popular science and really
did a lot of important work and still
are and there's actually a society that
speaks for those folks or to those folks
it's the Society of amateur scientists
yes I have a great online journal and a
lot of information for people that that
still want to you know invent time
travel in their basement or whatever one
of them probably will I hope that sort
of answers the question this may be more
of an observation that a question but it
might lead to further discussion of this
I had recently come from a conference on
citizen journalists and says the
journalism and there was clearly a
deliberate choice of the term there to
articulate a view of the role of the
individual relationship society that the
citizen is a an active member of society
contributes in constructive ways and so
forth I actually thought that might be
part of what the terms as a scientist
was trying to get an encouragement of
that I might change the whole nature of
what it means to be a citizen well you
know so I almost I'm 99.9% certain that
I can lay claim that having started the
use of this term and I was writing a
grant proposal to NSF was 1995 and I
said I don't want to call them
volunteers because some of them are
paying us and I don't want to call him
amateurs because it can be denigrating
what the heck are we gonna call folks
anymore and I said how about citizen
scientist and then I thought does that
sound too much like Citizen Kane and I
thought whatever and I wrote it down and
kind of the kind of the rest is history
now Alan Irwin published a book in 1995
in the UK called citizen science that
same year and he was referring using the
term to talk more about civic or
contributing to social policy which is a
very important field and he still works
in that area so there really was not a
lot of deliberation on my part to using
the word and I don't know how much
deliberation there was on anybody else's
part like the National Audubon Society
or the National Wildlife Federation that
just grabbed onto it now just this last
semester I co-taught a graduate seminar
in public engagement in science with
Bruce Lowenstein at Cornell who is
probably
Miller named to some of you and we spent
two weeks studying citizenship which I'd
never done before we read all kinds of
papers on citizenship and the question
was what did was it a good idea
that that I or if it wasn't me whoever
came up with this and and also I should
point out that at the 2007 conference
there were a lot of people in the room
who are upset with the term citizen
science because a lot of people are
afraid of the word citizen and right now
there's a lot of talk about immigration
so there's a lot of interesting
connotations with the word right now and
again that's why we got away from using
it in our report and switched over to
the PP SR but what I decided at first
during this graduate seminar listening
to graduate students who knew way more
than I did about citizenship theory
listening to them I first thought no I
wish I hadn't and you know it was really
civilian sciences really what we were
talking about non professional but then
the more I thought about it I decided
that what's really important to think
about is the citizenship of science and
the obligation that science as an
institute or institution globally
speaking has to the world to be
transparent and inclusive and tried to
make what we do something that not only
can anybody understand but can also
participate in so now I'm glad I did it
although I still think that people will
debate it forever and I'll just add one
little funny story is that I sat in
another seminar once listening to people
debate what the person who came up with
the term meant but I but I wasn't my
presence wasn't known in the room and
that was really really fun it was like
Mark Twain you know was it Tom Sawyer at
his own funeral or else all these people
that tried to figure out what Bob Dylan
was talking about in any of his songs
and he'll answer you hell if I know the
I'm I like the implication of the
journalism citizen journalist
where I do think both the idea that said
science has a responsibility to citizens
but also that part of citizenship
especially as we're entering a phase in
which the the public has a lot of
influence over the world citizen
citizenship does involve some kind of
scientific responsibility and I think a
good term to describe it is the
democratization of science which is
being enabled through these citizen
science projects and I'd also like to
say that the term citizen science it
isn't so well accepted in Australia the
term citizen has American connotations
to it so I prefer public participation
in research programs is that what your
new title is the area that has it better
it would be better accepted in Australia
I think yeah that's good to hear now
democratization of science I grabbed on
to that early on when I first heard it I
think that comes up a lot of that comes
out of the UK but I quickly discovered I
mean at the lab of ornithology
where I am a social scientist I'm most
of my my colleagues there are real
ornithologists and I discovered that the
democratization of science was what's
the word I'm looking for here that they
were worried about that was threatening
who was threatening to them to hear that
term so because they had spent their
whole life getting a PhD in studying and
they didn't want that democratized we
will offer a co-authorship to everybody
who contributed data now that that mean
that's probably not sustainable for a
lot of projects and a lot of projects
don't have that tradition in the field
but I think but you know in Australia
the other thing I should say is that in
astronomy and in physics authorship
author lists of more than 2,000 people
are now common in fact there are many
papers now in the physics literature in
which the author list is longer than the
body of the paper
and I and so for us it's much less of a
problem because we've kind of based that
issue but if we got to a hundred
thousand participants you know we I
don't think anybody has a real model for
that except you know me credit my
reference I know that the researchers I
work with in environmental sciences and
marine scientists if they're reusing
this data they will credit the coral
watch organization but not individuals
but there are initiatives around quite a
few and they're taking seem they're
making significant progress in standards
for data citation so then you can have
citations to particular data by
individuals contributed through citizen
science projects and those citations
would be within publications so I think
that these methods will enable specific
citation of individual contributions of
data through these projects yeah
actually that's a very generic problem
in all of the sciences now that use
heterogeneous data is that how you know
you there's another issue which is
related which is this repeatability
issue that in astronomy we're trying to
build systems so that if somebody wants
to repeat the analysis in a paper they
can and that requires not just citation
of the data but kind of deep links the
detailed provenance so for example if
someone analyzes all of the coral watch
state and then they generate a graph
which shows the trends in bleaching
events you need to know what data
they've use to generate those trends you
know what kind of statistical analysis
they've used to generate the graph and
so there's also significant work going
on on the capturing the detailed
provenance of the derived data from the
citizens
and there's issues there of the data
evolving under you so there's you want
to be able to roll back the data a
referee might want to roll back the data
and see what the data looked like at the
time that this analysis was performed
and its technical issues there that are
no more questions from the audience I
will use my moderator privilege and to
ask one question and that um there
appears to be two dimensions to citizen
science and one seems to be more
prominent in our discussion here and
that's the one day how do we get data
that already exists the citizens
collects how we can how can we integrate
them into our projects and engage with
them then there's the educational part
educating the citizen participants on
the work that they're already doing and
to learn more from the scientists and
then I see like a as far as this stuff
dimension of that second dimension how
can you engage people who are not
already bird watchers or who are not
diving and not already interested in
this information in the science how do
you engage them and I think with a
particular look towards climate change
which David mentioned in ik there is a
certain responsibility as to like what
we as scientists know and and there's a
response that citizens need to take so
several of you work on climate change
related projects Jane and and Rick
mentioned that how how do you how do you
get to people who are not already
engaged and how can you use your citizen
science the tools to to get more people
involved and to to respond to the
scientific information that you that is
produced
I have since I'm not named I have a
comment when one thing is that you know
we were discussing last night over
dinner we were discussing unschooling
the idea that people should learn what
they're interested in rather what than
what school you know pushes on them and
that we were talking about that a little
bit and when and in that model citizen
science is best done by people who are
already excited at some level about the
subjects but I agree actually that one
of the goals of these projects is to
actually create new astronomers new
birdwatchers new divers and with a
deeper understanding of what they're
doing and I think first of all I think
it's a hard problem but second of all I
think one thing that's definitely
happening in education this is now
schooling not on the schooling education
in America at least is there's a lot of
emphasis on and I think quite rightly on
students performing their own research
like activities and then evolving to
doing true research activities and I
think that and that that whole mode of
learning is kind of searching for
outlets but these citizen science
projects produce incredible
opportunities to give students in school
or unschooled students a way to to learn
about research so I somehow I feel like
it's connected to childhood and
education well I have so many responses
to that question okay so the first one
is I have no idea and if you can figure
it out
you know if I knew we'd have a lot more
people in our projects another response
is a little bit like where David started
here which was give me a break
look what we're doing already and now
you want me to get more people involved
where we already have thousands and
thousands of people who are finding
something meaningful and important to do
with their hobby and to feel empowered
in society and now you want me to reach
out and I I say that partly
tongue-in-cheek and partly out of
exhaustion especially from NSF with the
underserved audience I've been
for 25 years been trying to figure this
out now that said we are trying really
hard in our celebrate urban birds
project for example the simplified
version of e bird is designed to bring
Latino or Hispanic depending on where
you are audiences into e bird and
citizen science through the Performing
Arts and through other arts and cultural
ways of appealing to the family
structure and we've done a lot of work
with that right here in New York City
with bird festivals and they they almost
get tricked into recording some other
data now I don't know I don't have
enough long-term data to know what kind
of longevity or retention we have there
yeah and then also what David said we do
have curricula that work in middle
schools and in those cases the kids
don't really have an option if the
teacher says you're going to do this
then they do it and some of them do find
out that they are interested and get
hooked and we had some anecdotes about
kids who have gotten hooked that would
make you just cry huge tears you know if
you heard about some of the kids who
stopped going to recess and went to shop
to build birdhouses to give to their
families for Christmas you know it's a
handful but it keeps us going I think
people came to leave but I'll just
quickly say I think get them when
they're young which is what the other
two have said rewards and recognition so
the one where students will fail if they
don't do this work as if it's part of
the curriculum but rewards as a
marketing tool on the website so the
people who are the best contributors go
to the top of the list
some projects give them gifts if they
reach the top of the list so they get
cups they get t-shirts someone suggests
a free beer but that's rather hard to
deliver on and especially if they're
underage you might get into trouble and
recognition again through the website so
rewards and recognition are very
important I think I think this concludes
our session today thank you very much to
the speakers thank you to a great
audience with great questions
and go and thank you too Catherine Pope
for you